gun ownership in this country
became a ideological issue and a
partisan issue in ways that it shouldn't
be
it has become sort of a proxy for
arguments about our culture wars you
know Urban versus rural race is always
an element in these issues issues of you
know our class of class and and
education and so forth and so instead of
just taking a very practical approach
like we do let's say for example with
car safety right where we say all right
we got a bunch of accidents let's
have seat belts inside let's make cars
safer and let's engineer roads so that
we prevent them instead of thinking
about it in a very pragmatic way we end
up really arguing about identity and
emotion and all kinds of stuff that does
not have to do with keeping our children
safe